[Música]
qué pasaría si lo que hoy por sentado
mañana me abandona
y si mi carrera deja de estar necesaria
para el momento en el que me reciba
y si mañana me gustan las chicas
y si tengo que cambiar lo que creo para
encajar en un grupo o conseguir un
trabajo
y si directamente no encajo
tengo miedo
mucho miedo
a veces ese miedo me genera angustia
otras veces me pide a gritos que lo
hable con amigos e incluso que lo
mantengo oculto
y a veces me para visa
mi miedo viene de la mano de la realidad
en la que vivo junto con otros
adolescentes creo que somos una
generación a la que le inquieta todo y
como tal queremos actuar al respecto
somos la generación que abrazó la
diversidad natural hizo la
homosexualidad y que incluso protesta
contra el maltrato animal a través de su
alimentación
pero si bien pareciera que estamos
dispuestos a hacerle frente a todo eso
no significa que no tengamos miedo
son miedos potenciados por la
estabilidad de los cambios a nivel
global en materia económica así como
también en materia política social e
incluso tecnológica
no sé qué voy a hacer mañana antes no
sabemos qué vamos a hacer dentro de unas
horas y mucho menos qué va a pasar
mañana
quizás es un día normal o quizás es uno
de esos en los que salen seis nuevos
modelos de celulares se desploman las
bolsas del mundo salen tres nuevas redes
sociales con los mismos filtros de
perritos o suceden atentados terroristas
en centros de ciudades como parís o
barcelona que dejan a decenas de muertos
hoy me paro aquí
con 19 años y toda mi vida por delante y
lo único que estoy segura es que me
llamo clara
aunque quizás mañana me llame pedro
hoy me compro ropa y para cuando salí al
local hay otra tendencia
hoy aprendo algo y mañana no me sirve
para nada y es ahí donde me cae la ficha
donde me doy cuenta de lo alejada que
estoy de quienes me antecedieron por qué
cambios existieron siempre pero hoy no
hay sistema aplicable un consejo que
seguir
una receta que aplicar un consejo que
nos permita alcanzar nuestros objetivos
o mínimamente hacer frente a todo
aquello que debemos afrontar
no sé cómo voy a vivir mañana y mucho
menos cómo voy a vivir de acá a 10 años
no sé si la inteligencia artificial va a
remplazar a mi carrera
no sé si vamos a comprar casas o si
vamos a vivir en conventillos
inteligentes o adentro de nuestros autos
eléctricos e incluso no sé si voy a
tener una familia propia
se siente y lógico buscar permanencia en
un mundo tan cambiante y no sé bien que
hacer pero creo que lo único que me va a
ayudar a salir es adaptarme al cambio
adaptarme abrazarlo y animarme a
presentarme
es por eso que cuando pienso en mi
proyecto de vida yo no pienso en hitos
fijos a cumplir a lo largo del tiempo
sino en tres principios que creo que se
van a mantener estables incluso cuando
todo lo demás cambie
primero
ser la mejor versión de mí misma
siempre
2º adueñarme de mi presente y futuro
inmediatos por ejemplo esta semana
quiero levantarme temprano ni bien suena
el despertador para aprovechar el día o
este mes quiero probar mis parciales
y tercero me voy a proponer objetivos
flexibles en el largo plazo
este personalmente es el principio que
más me cuesta porque tengo una ligera
tendencia a buscar rigidez o puntualidad
incluso cuando soy consciente de que las
cosas probablemente no se ven como yo lo
espero
es por eso que por el momento mi mejor
ejemplo de este principio es el
dedicarme estudiaron solo lo que me
motive
por el momento me quiero recibir en
tiempo y forma y lo veo posible porque
estoy enamoradísima de la profesión que
elegir pero si en el medio del proceso
sufre un desencanto quiero tener el
valor para cambiar de camino porque
tener miedo
está bien
es algo que a todos nos ha pasado y ya
los adolescentes de los próximos 10 años
también les va a pasar que mis hijos si
es que decidió tenerlos también le va a
pasar
creo que esos hijos hipotéticos voy a
tener que darles todo lo que yo necesito
hoy y eso no son fórmulas mágicas o
recetas que nos quedaron viejas lo que
van a necesitar es cariño
y que ese cariño sea una certeza para la
construcción de un futuro que se muestra
tan incierto futuro que van a construir
en base a aciertos y errores ya cambios
propios de su adolescencia que ellos
también van a tener que abrazar así como
hoy me toca a mí porque eso es lo que yo
necesito hoy y estoy casi segura de que
mañana también
o quizás no
gracias
[Música]